well a nick indeed you took a few more
minutes than the ones i had a sign for
your presentation but anyways you
presented this how many pages book
almost 700 pages book I think you did a
fantastic job and thank you for your
presentation and of course we will
continue to discuss what you have said
here throughout the day I now invite
chris hope of Cambridge University who
is I would say the lead author of the
page model which was used extensively by
unique in preparing his review so Chris
please take the floor so I've got just
20 minutes now also to talk a little bit
about page 2002 which was the integrated
assessment model as Nick said used in
the stern review and to talk about what
it can tell us about the social cost of
carbon which is you know is the impact
of one more ton of carbon being put into
the atmosphere now in the form of co2
and I hope at the end I'll be able to
talk a little bit more about some of the
other things that the page 2002 model
can do for us as we try and decide what
to do about this serious problem what
I'm going to talk about is just a little
bit on the structure of the model itself
so you can see what's involved in it
talk a little bit about the values that
come out for the social cost of carbon
in the stern review and explain where
those numbers come from one of the Von
Teese of the model is that it is
transparent and I want to make those
numbers transparent to you so we can
understand where they come from then
lead a little bit into talking about
what happens to the social cost of
carbon the impacts of a ton of carbon
dioxide if we make some other
assumptions to answer some of the
comments that have been made and this in
a way leads us into the discussion that
we'll be having this afternoon and then
talk for a few minutes at the end about
what else the page 2002 model
so very simply the page 2002 model is an
integrated assessment model it divides
the world up into eight regions he looks
at all the major greenhouse gases not
just carbon dioxide it allows you to
make decisions about abatement how
you're going to cut back your emissions
of gases and adaptation how you're going
to cope with any impacts that might be
caused it looks at economic non-economic
and catastrophic impacts the kinds of
things that Nick was talking about we
should be very worried about if we get
temperatures above four five six degrees
maybe it has a time horizon out to 2200
because this is a hugely difficult and
long term problem and most importantly
nick has emphasized uncertainty all the
way through his talk all of the
calculations in the model are done with
a recognition of that uncertainty so
they're done probabilistically you don't
just put in single values for parameters
and get out single answers you put in
ranges for parameters and get out ranges
for answers and what kinds of things you
need to put into the model to be able to
do these calculations you need to have
some statements about what the emissions
of greenhouse gases are likely to be you
need to make some statements about
atmospheric residence time of the
greenhouse gases how long are they going
to be there how sensitive is the climate
system and it's shown a slide on the
assumptions that are in there about that
you need to look at sulfates and the
cooling effects of those so this is sort
of scientific information that needs to
go into the model to be able to do the
calculations but also you need to look
at how impacts are as a percent of GDP
and how those very as a function of the
temperature changes and you need to look
at the discount rates inequity way it's
the kind of economic parameters that
make us talking about and this is what
makes it an integrated assessment model
he puts in values from the scientific
studies values from the economic studies
brings them together and allows us to
say what kind of implications they have
for the policies we might want to follow
and the structure of the model basically
to run the model you need to make some
decisions about what your abatement and
adaptation policy is going to be in all
the different world regions how much of
the gases you're going to allow to be
emitted what kind of
you're going to have you can then
calculate through on the left-hand side
the blue on my screen there sort of a
gray on your screen which works out the
global and regional temperatures that
results from the different emissions of
gases and if we look at the amount of
adaptation that can then in combination
with the temperatures tell us what the
impacts are likely to be I won't talk
about very much the things on the other
side of the the right-hand side of the
model which allows us also to say what
are the costs of adaptation what are the
costs of abatement and get some some
costs of taking action as well but i
will refer to that at the end so what
you actually do if you're wanting to
work out the social costs of a
greenhouse gas in this case carbon
dioxide well here's a side showing what
the emissions might be over time under
scenario a to one of the IPCC scenarios
you can use the model to calculate in
each region and each time period what
impacts are likely to be in a
probabilistic sense for those emissions
and then you can aggregate them up over
the regions and aggregating them back
through time and aggregate them across
different outcomes as Nick was talking
about to give an estimate of what the
total impacts are likely to be if you
have emissions under that blue line
there and then you can do exactly the
same thing with emissions just the same
as under the blue line except for that
little tiny red triangle taken off at
the beginning and you can work through
again all the impacts that there will be
in the different regions over time over
the different outcomes with that
scenario exactly the same except for
that little red triangle there and then
you can take away one from the other and
as that little red triangle actually
represents 1 billion tons of carbon if
you then divide the difference between
the two scenarios by 1 billion that will
then tell you how much impact is being
caused by one ton of carbon being
emitted today and that's the way these
kind of calculations are done to work
out the social costs the marginal
impacts so what kinds of figures do we
get from the stone review here's the
number for the social cost of carbon
that is most prominent in the review a
figure of 85 dollars per ton of co2
which translates through as three
hundred and twelve dollars per ton of
carbon which is
more usual unit that people measured in
as nick said this has been calculated
using the page 2002 model with sets of
assumptions in there and transforming
the answers using balanced growth
equivalents and so on afterwards in
order to be able to produce this
expected number now the first thing we
can do with the model is say well okay
let's make all the assumptions exactly
the same as in the stern review and
let's rather than just produce one
number the central number let's see what
kind of range of numbers comes out of
the model and this is what's shown on
this slide I put stone review here in
inverted commas because this isn't the
answers using the balanced growth
equivalent clever mechanism but Nick and
his team have been able to do this is
the answer just taking the numbers in
terms of the effect on GDP transformed
using equity weights and you can see
that we can end up reproduce in the
answers from the stone review pretty
closely the mean value that comes out of
the model when you run it like that is
three hundred and forty dollars just a
little bit higher than the central
number produced in the cern review and
the range is somewhere now as you see a
five to ninety five percent range
between 65 and nine hundred dollars a
ton of carbon so immediately you see
just how uncertain we are about this
even using all parameters pretty much
exactly the same as in the stern review
we end up with a range for social costs
so calm that an order of magnitude or a
bit higher as being not unreasonable for
the ninety percent range one of the
advantages of having a probabilistic
model like page is that you can
immediately get out of it some
information about which of all the
uncertain inputs that are in the model
has the biggest effects on the answers
that you're getting out in this case the
answers for the social cost of carbon
and we can see here that it's a mixture
of the scientific information and the
economic information that goes in there
the most important parameter the one
with the longest line here is the
climate sensitivity uncertainty about
that has the biggest impact
the answer we get for the social cost of
carbon the next most important is the
pure time preference rate that you
assume and so on down the third one is
the impact function exponent that [ __ ]
spent some time talking about as being
an important parameter we can see indeed
from here is one of the top parameters
here so this tells me this graph what
parameters I need to tell you about what
inputs I need to tell you about to get
you to understand why the answers in the
center of you come out roughly as they
did and so that's what the next few
slides are going to do the assumptions
in the stern review runs which ended up
with that so range of social cost of
carbon that I showed a moment ago are
these the GDP the population and the
emissions are as in the IPCC scenario a
to climate sensitivity has arranged
somewhere between one and a half and
five degrees centigrade for a doubling
of co2 concentrations most likely answer
two and a half degrees the little
triangles of the NGO this is a
triangular distribution with the bottom
point being the minimum the top one
being the maximum and the middle number
being the most likely input so as Nick
said this is very standard assumptions
about climate sensitivity standard
assumptions about the half life of
climate change how long it takes on
average the earth to respond to any
change in forcing between 25 and 75
years the impact inputs the economic
impacts in the European Union in the
model in these stern review runs are
assumed to be somewhere between minus
nor point one percent a one percent of
GDP for a two and a half degrees
centigrade rise in other words the model
does allow a possibility that global
warming could actually be a good thing
could lead to benefits rather than costs
in regions like the European Union
however the non-economic impacts the
effects on health effects on inundation
of wetlands and so on the don't get
directly into GDP are assumed to be
somewhere between zero one and a half
percent of GDP for two and a half
degrees centigrade rise now impacts in
India or the poor countries are greater
than this as a multiplicative factor on
there maybe twice as high in terms of
percent of GDP lost but the impacts in
the rest of the OECD are lower than this
there may be only a quarter to a half
the impacts in the EU because he you
happen to have quite a long coastline it
since
quite vulnerable to things like sea
level rise what assumptions would be
made about how the impacts grow as a
power of temperature well here they are
it grows us somewhere between a linear
and the cubic function of temperature
for the most likely thing is that gross
just slightly more than linear with
temperature so as temperature goes up it
goes up as a 1 1 point third power of
temperature now there are some fairly
aggressive assumptions about adaptation
in the model adaptation is assumed to
remove any economic impacts in the OECD
for temperature rise up to 2 degrees
centigrade assume we can perfectly adapt
to temperatures up to that sort of level
and if we go beyond that to assume that
adaptation if we work hard at it can
reduce the economic impacts in the OCD
by ninety percent compared to what their
safety that is in that first line
they're not so effective in poor
countries may be reducing backs by 50%
without apt a shin and a non economic
impacts again it's not quite so easy to
see how we might be able to adapt
against inundation of wetlands and so on
so it's assume that adaptation reduces
norm economic impacts just by twenty
five percent but this fairly aggressive
adaptation there the discounting in AP
weights I don't need to labor because
Nick's talked about them pure time
preference rate in these runs that I've
shown or point one percent a year the
etta parameter I call it the US system r
j- consumption it's the same thing it's
minus 1 and the equity weights are
applied by multiplying the impacts in
each world region by that little
equation at the bottom and the effect of
that equation is that if you have a
dollars worth of impact in a poor
country it's weighted more highly than a
dollars worth of impact in the rich
country and then finally what kind of
assumptions are made in these runs in
terms of the possibility of catastrophe
catastrophic think the thing which you
really perhaps be worried about if the
temperature rises a long way it's assume
that there's no chance of this kind of
catastrophic impacts if the temperature
stays below about 5 degrees with a range
of from 2 to 8 degrees above
pre-industrial levels if you have well
we get above that threshold it's a tumor
there's a chance of catastrophe rising
by ten percent for every 1 degree
centigrade we go above this and if we do
get that kind of catastrophe the impacts
are quite severe in the EU you would
lose between five and twenty percent of
your GDP with
most likely value of ten percent of GDP
so they are the main inputs to the model
if you use those inputs I don't think
any of them are outrageous or well
outside the range of numbers that come
from the literature you will end up with
a social cost of carbon round about
three hundred dollars per ton with a
range of maybe from 60 to nine hundred
dollars a ton it's just that's what
happens when you use these kind of
inputs but of course if you don't
believe those inputs if you don't think
those inputs are right then you will end
up with different values for the social
cost of carbon and therefore different
implications for what you should do in
terms of policy and what I'm going to do
is just run through a few changes that
you might make the input numbers and see
what effect they have on the social cost
of carbon I'm not going to do all of
these because I know we're short of time
so I'll just run through slides that I
skipper there in the website
presentation that's being put together
by the organizers of the meeting so you
can look at them if you think I've
skipped over something that looks really
interesting you can go look at it there
or of course ask me about it in the
discussion so the kinds of comments that
there have been and this sort of leaves
into this afternoon on the results are
well maybe this estimate of catastrophes
not quite right that that we've got in
the model maybe it should be either
lower or higher and maybe the
assumptions we've made about pure time
preference rate and the US tissa T of
the marginal utility of consumption that
are wrong they end up giving you a
discount rate is lower than we observe I
couldn't skip over that one just say
well it's ok the assumptions that we
made for catastrophe in the in the stern
review runs end up giving you may be a
two and a half percent chance of the
circuit s trophy by twenty one hundred
and twenty five percent chance that
there's a catastrophe by 2200 and maybe
some people would say actually it's more
likely than that here's some parameters
which try and take that into account if
instead of saying we can't have any
catastrophe until the temperature rises
by five degrees we say well maybe we
could start having a possibility of
catastrophe goes above three degrees
with the range of two to four and if the
chance of a catastrophic impact rise is
not by ten percent for every 1 degree
centigrade above this but by twenty
percent then we end up with values for
the social cost of carbon
about fifty percent higher $500 as a
most likely value rather than three
hundred and forty dollars even though
even with the new values for a higher
possibility of curse tree there's still
only about a twenty five percent chance
that you'll have one by 2100 and about
an eighty percent chance you'll have one
by 2200 so you're talking about things
that are most likely to occur in the
22nd century over a hundred years from
now and yet they still have quite a big
effect on the social cost of carbon
today to do that one I'll do this one
what happens if you take a different
ethical position from Nick and his team
what happens if you assume that the pure
time preference rate is a bit higher
maybe somewhere in the range of zero to
three percent a year most likely one
percent and what happens if you assume
the elasticity margin utility of the
consumption again has a range going up
to minus 2 the kind of number that Nick
was talking about and maybe down to
minus 9.5 and what happens if you assume
those inputs are perfectly correlated so
you end up with the kinds of consumption
discount rates of the order of four
percent a year that we tend to see in
the economy as a whole what the answer
then is if you use exactly the same
scheme for doing equity waiting and
discounting you end up with a social
cost of carbon that's about forfeits
lower the mean value goes down to about
seventy dollars per ton of carbon and
the range from 10 to about two hundred
dollars but that's not really the end of
the story because if you were wanting to
use this kind of experiment about higher
purer time preference rates and range
for the elasticity marginal utility of
consumption you would probably want to
go the whole hog and do the kinds of
different runs that a lot of economists
have suggested we should do whereas you
basically two eighths not on the average
world average gdp per capita in a
particular year but you should base them
on today's EU GDP per capita and you
should then discount your utility
impacts not at the consumption discount
rate but just at the pure time
preference rate and if you do that then
keep everything exactly the same as an
experiment for which I just showed you
the value for the social cost of
Parliament mean value not only comes
back up from seventy dollars per ton of
carbon back up to 380 days higher
mean value about four hundred and thirty
dollars per ton of carbon so you know
there's clearly a lot to be discussed
about and I know we're going to discuss
this more this afternoon and that'll be
good because one of the advantages of
having a model like this around is that
when you get different views on what
should be put in four different
parameters the model is there you're
able to run them through and see what
implications did have in terms of social
cost of carbon and therefore the policy
that you should take what I'm going to
do now is just run through in the last
three or four minutes some other things
that you can get out of this kind of
integrated assessment model these are
results that come from runs done before
the stone review so typically with
higher up your time preference rates
than the northpoint one percent per year
that nyx team has used and therefore the
social cost of carbon that you get from
those kind of runs might be down around
forty dollars as a mean value but
because you're putting all the other
greenhouse gases in the equation as well
in the model as well you can work out
what's the social cost of the other
greenhouse gases to you can work out how
much emphasis you should be placing on
reducing methane reducing sulfur
hexafluoride all the other gases
compared to reducing carbon and if we're
going to solve this problem we're not
going to just do it by techlink carbon
dioxide although we're going to have to
tackle the other greenhouse gases as
well the model can also tell you if you
take that little red triangle of
emissions the way not in the base here
today but at some point like twenty ten
or twenty twenty or twenty forty what
happens to the social cost of carbon
over time and the social cost of other
greenhouse gases over time and here we
can see in blue the values for what
happens to the social cost of carbon
over time and in purple what value
happens to the social cost of methane
over time and they're calibrated sites
that there are the scales so that they
look equal in the base year today and
you can see that what happens is that
they both increase over time they
increase because as we get closer to the
time when you would expect the most
severe impacts of climate change to
occur then the extra impact that you'll
get from putting another turn into the
atmosphere gets higher the mean value
for the social cost of carbon goes up at
about two and a half percent a year the
mean value for the social cost of
methane goes are more than that at over
three percent a year and that's to do
with the different lifetimes at the
different gases in the atmosphere I can
explain it in the discussion of people
want to
more about it so that's another thing
you can do we need to think not just
what's going to have once you'll be used
for the social costs today which might
set us a carbon price or a methane price
today but how is that going to have to
change over the future as we carry on
with this policy that's going to have to
be there for decades if we're going to
make any impact on this and then if you
bring in the other side of the little
guy little structure page diagram that I
had right at the beginning and say okay
let's look at the costs of doing
something about this problem the costs
about apt ation the costs of abatement
as well as the impacts you can add those
two things together you can add together
the total impacts that are left from
climate change in the cost of doing
something about the problem and you can
then begin to say okay what kind of
policies can we put in place that will
try and minimize those costs again
aggregated over space and time and all
the different outcomes in a
probabilistic way and you end up perhaps
with some lines like that to blue
optimal line on the graph that's the
sort of set of policies that might end
up minimizing the sum of the action
costs the cost of doing something about
the problem and the impact costs the
costs of climate change as a whole and
you see that even with much lower values
for social cost of carbon then we get in
the stern review those kind of optimal
emissions are likely to end up leading
down to quite low emissions as we go
further into the future and if you have
that if you can do something clever with
genetic algorithm type methods which
allow you to work out an optimal path of
emissions even under uncertainty then
you can do something which is really
quite valuable for the research
community as well and say okay that's
our optimal path if we don't know any
more about the problem if we've got this
huge uncertainty that we have at the
moment it's the blue dotted line there
what happens if we get some better
information in say 10 years time in
twenty ten or in 2020 well in this case
it shows what happens if we get better
information about the climate
sensitivity this very important
scientific parameter not that we get
perfect information we know exactly what
it is in 2020 but it's just a bit better
we reduce the range by about a half
compared to what it is today obviously
if you get information that the climate
sensitivity is towards the low end of
the range then the opto emissions will
be higher degree
line there if you get information that
these climate sensitivity is towards the
high end of the range the red line your
optimal emissions will end up being
lower and by looking at the total costs
of impacts and costs of taking action
once we've got this better information
you can work out what the value of this
information is to you and I see turns
out the value of this information is
enormously high if we get information
that it harv's the range of our climate
sensitivity parameter in 2010 that's
worth about 400 billion dollars to us if
we get that information in 2020 it's
worth about 300 billion dollars to us
not quite as much because we aren't able
to take action quite so early but that
gives you some kind of impetus for
thinking about what kind of research you
should be doing and how much you should
be how much you should be spending on
these kind of scientific and economic
studies that we need to do it also of
course assumes that people take notice
of them and will adjust their emissions
optimally as a result of them but you
know we all have to make some kind of
assumption there and so that's it really
what I've tried to do is be as
transparent and open as I can about what
goes into this model that's at the heart
of the review calculating these kind of
numbers show that the numbers that are
in there are not outrageous they're sort
of fairly standard and what happens if
you if you change some of them of course
the model isn't perfect it carries on
being developed as the new by PCC
results come out this year will want to
have new versions of it and keep it
going and what I'd like to say of course
is if anybody has any questions about
what I've run through here or would like
to think about using the model
themselves to run through their own
assumptions that they might have which
might be different from the ones I've
shown here well that's the great
advantage of having the model there
means we can do that kind of runs and
see what different assumptions to in
terms of the policies we want to take
and I'd be very happy to work with
anybody who might want to do that okay
thank you very much